ahora vamos a agregar una lente a
nuestra cámara estenopeica en la lección
anterior exploramos cómo las lentes
curvan o refractan los rayos de luz
paralelos entrantes y los concentran en
un solo punto conocido como punto focal
llamamos distancia focal de la lente a
la distancia que va desde la lente hasta
el punto focal bien si un objeto está
muy lejos de la lente todos los rayos de
luz que se desprenden de él son de hecho
paralelos como estos y se concentran en
este punto que es la distancia efe de la
lente
en la primera lección vimos esta
relación pero ahora pensemos en los
objetos cercanos donde entran en foco es
decir donde tenemos que poner el plano
de la imagen para que la imagen se vea
nítida para empezar necesitamos
introducir algunas nuevas variables como
dijimos en la primera lección
efe es la distancia focal de la lente
sea o la distancia hacia el objeto que
queremos enfocar y dejemos que
represente la distancia desde la lente
cuando el objeto entre en foco llamemos
a esto plano focal
entonces necesitamos desarrollar una
fórmula que nos permita calcular y a
partir de f
antes de poder hacerlo es necesario que
examinemos más detalladamente cómo las
lentes refractan la luz
de hecho la fracción es un poco compleja
y se describe mediante una ecuación
llamada la ley de snl la cual no
necesitamos aquí porque vamos a hacer
una importante simplificación por medio
de una aproximación a una lente delgada
lo cual hace que sea más fácil resolver
los cálculos la aproximación a la lente
delgada dice que ninguno de los rayos
que pasan a través del centro de la
lente se curvan completamente permanecen
rectos a estos rayos se les llama rayos
principales sabemos que los rayos
paralelos se retractan a medida que
pasan a través de la lente y atraviesa
en el punto focal de la lente ese punto
está a una distancia efe de la lente
sobre el eje x así pues la distancia
focal define el punto en que un rayo
paralelo atraviesa el eje x
ahora tenemos dos rayos principal y
paralelo que salen de nuestro objeto y
el punto donde los dos rayos se
intersectan define la distancia y a la
que los objetos entran en foco la parte
realmente genial de la aproximación a la
lente delgada es que dice que todos los
rayos que salen de este punto entrarán
en foco en el mismo lugar
del mismo modo todos los puntos en el
plano paralelo a la lente y a una
distancia o entrarán en foco en el mismo
plano del otro lado razón por la que la
llamamos nuestro plano focal
si podemos calcular el punto de
intersección de esos dos rayos entonces
sabremos dónde entrarán en foco todos
los rayos de este objeto esto es genial
bien hagamos una pausa aquí para que
puedas desarrollar tu comprensión de
este diagrama con el siguiente ejercicio